in your sermons in your private life
what is the passage in the Quran that is
one you find yourself returning to
often you know the part of the Quran I
get asked this question that resonates
with me most uh usually has to do with
what is heaviest for me at the
moment um there is a verse in the
chapter of Mary
um a part of the
verse your lord does not
forget your lord does not
forget and
so you know as you see what's
transpiring right
now our hope is not in creation our hope
is in our creator and our hope is not in
this life our hope is in the
afterlife and so that verse deeply
resonates because I think that
you know many of us often wonder how are
they going to rebuild how are they going
to get past
this and we know that God has a way of
restoring
everything God will restore everything
if not in this life then in the
next so there's an
eternal flame of hope that burns there
yeah and the people of Gaza have it the
people of Gaza have it you know
you can be more easily deluded by this
material world if you're Hostage to it
but the people of Gaza have never been
duded by the material world because they
never really had it they've always been
attached to a greater idea to a greater
place and
so it is part of the secret ingredient
that they have right that they believe
and something greater than this and so
you can't survive hell on Earth unless
you believe in Paradise outside of
it